I think there's a reasonable chance that
that Trump just wins outright in
November 2024 and human nature being
what it is a lot of people will talk
themselves into the fact that well okay
maybe it won't be so bad uh and you you
make the opposite argument in this book
which is like no it's going to be
terrible and here's exactly why and you
did it with very specific detail which I
found impressive uh and scary so help
paint a picture for listeners let's say
Trump comes in office 2025 what comes
next well a couple of things really
caught me off guard and how candid
former advisors of trump were and
willing to use their names in this book
on the record I mean a number of former
intelligence officials who I spoke to
warned that they felt like in a second
term the ex-president would use
America's spy community and spy agencies
to exact revenge against political
Rivals I find this to be incredibly
likely because even when I was in the
administration Trump asked white house
chief of staff John Kelly if he could
wiretap the phones of White House staff
because he was worried about them
leaking against him he wanted to
politicize the intelligence community
and in the second term I had a number of
current and former officials warned me
that he would use the fisa powers which
is essentially the tool that allows a
president in extreme circumstances with
judicial approval to listen to civilian
conversations in the United States he
would use those Powers against domestic
political adversaries and that was a
real concern but the the worry about
weaponization of government went even
deeper than that Andrew especially when
it was the justice department that came
up current and former FBI officials and
doj officials uh predicted that he would
form special counsels to prosecute
political Rivals and they anticipate him
fully gutting the Federal Bureau of
Investigation I mean we're talking about
institutions that Americans rely on to
protect them against criminals
terrorists foreign nation states being
hijacked by a White House to exact
revenge and while I was writing this
Andrew you know even I felt like some of
the language was extreme and then Donald
Trump himself came out about two months
ago and basically said the theme of his
re-election effort would be retribution
he said I am your retribution I am your
revenge so this notion of coming back
into office and weaponizing the federal
government uh is something that is a
front and center priority to him and I
heard that again and again across
departments and agencies how he would
weaponize DHS and DOD and the Department
of Education I'll give you one more
example Andrew uh you know the former
Chief of Staff to the Department of
Education Trump's hand-picked person to
be Chief of Staff in the Department of
Education said that if he's re-elected
he'll Implement a policy he really
wanted to implement in the first term
which was to kick all immigrant children
out of public schools what am I saying
by that there's millions of undocumented
people in the United States they have
children in public schools an executive
order was drafted in the first term to
cut off all federal funds to any public
school where there was undocumented
children and to kick them out if they
wanted to get money in fact he called
this the Cockroach that wouldn't die
that's what the chief the staff at
Trump's Department of Education called
it and he said in the second term
they'll do it
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you